the all-time leading rusher the National
Football League Pro Football Hall of
Famer and a friend which I'm pleased to
say Emmitt Smith's good to see you amber
it is always good to see you my friend
remember when you came on NFL Network
Super Bowl coverage back in 2005 after
the old four season dry right and you
were I was interviewing you in
Jacksonville right and you just
announced your retirement correct and
you said hey I might want to do this
talking thing for business I'm available
for all sorts of conversations have you
said remember that yes yes and lo and
behold we started working together and
we did you know what I enjoyed my time
working with you guys over at the NFL
Network it was a lot of you guys over
there so you guys have a great team
right now conveying the message of the
NFL talking about the league itself the
players different things that goes on
you've always been a professional
I've always enjoyed having conversation
right back at you and and we did Monday
Night Football coverage it was me you
and now and now Hall defend with TV Hall
of Famer Terrell Davis yes yes great
great weekend at the Hall of Fame sin TD
Gideon alone with LT who is also part of
the NFL Network so the TD and I used to
enjoy Monday night coverages those fun
taking as we would call the halftime
lunch break I do recall halftime lunch
break sometimes I went into the third
quarter yeah well no well on occasion I
wouldn't have coming back to after the
game is over anyway so but it was it was
a total blast and then speaking of LT
and the Hall of Fame he told a great
story
during his induction speech about
meeting you at a football camp right
because he saw and then how his mom
saved money so he could go to that camp
and what meeting you and how what what
it meant to him what was what it mean to
you to hear that you're on the other end
it just goes to show that you never know
how you might might have an impact in
another person's life and so to have
that kind of an experience with LT and
the many kids that were at that camp
including the camps that I put on you
don't know in two years later when they
have an opportunity to either see you
personally and thank you
or to get up on a podium like alt did at
the Hall of Fame last weekend and thank
you again and so fortunately for me he
continued on to play football and I saw
him at the Doak Walker Award as well
that he reminded me of that and then
when he was a TC year when he first
outed tell you that so you have heard
this story yes I have heard this story
before and and then watching them play
in the natural but here's a kid that
came in with the vision of making his
mark on the game and and doing
everything in his power to do that and
he has taken the lessons and the life
lessons that his mom has taught him his
dad is also coaches and others and
applied it to become a Hall of Famer
it's a beautiful thing to see
Emmitt Smith here on the Rich Eisen show
and then you know obviously Jerry Jones
going in right to the Hall of Fame now I
could not help but notice am it the
number of verbal bouquets that Jerry
threw in the direction of Jimmie Johnson
as Jimmy sat on the stage as a presenter
for Jason Taylor about gosh felt like
three days before but it was still the
same night as how long the night went
did do you think that there's a chance
here that these two guys can mend
whatever fences still need mending here
I think those fences have been mend they
have I think they have I just think most
people want to continue to harp on what
the issue was then I think that now is
so much greater than it was then I think
they both have appreciated the abilities
that that that they they collectively
have enjoyed in terms of working
together having success together and
also mutually at the time we may have
been a rift publicly but I think over
over time Jimmy has always been there
for for Jerry whenever Jerry called is
that right yeah huh yeah because you
know the way up people talk about and
I've heard too is that that these guys
still need to get one more maybe sit
down that you and herb and Troy need to
maybe broker but other guys where they
sit down everything gets ironed out
trust me time heals all wounds and and
and and been able to
bless another person in a way that says
you know I really do appreciate you I
think that's the way Jerry does Jerry
does it in his own subtle way and I
think Jimmy understands that I think
Jimmy is a student enough to know that
you know some things just need to be
buried I mean you cannot take away the
success that Jimmy was able to have with
the Dallas Cowboys you cannot have that
success
Jerry cannot have that success without
Jimmy Johnson been in the pit in place
do you think you could have been
successful if there was no drama do you
think that that was necessary for you
guys to win you know it Smith I cannot
say no because we had to deal with it
and we were still successful and we also
had our challenges I mean you cannot
have a great success without having
great challenges I think it's in the
challenges where you've really developed
the strength that you need to persevere
through things that are unforeseen and I
think going through it all with when I
look at what we all went through I think
it made us better I think it made us
better as men
it forces forced us to grow up and and
become more accountable to ourselves and
to each other and not lean on a coach as
much take on that self responsibility
and become more leaders and I think
that's what it did for us now when you
say Emmett Smith grow up does that mean
Irvin has grown up I think now for
everybody but now on the other side of
50 what do they know Michael Michael is
a unique character and here and Michael
has so much wisdom he's a truly as a
wise guy one of the hardest workers I've
ever been around a vocal leader a
passionate person and and we all grow up
at in our own ways and not to say that
Michael has never grown up Michael
enjoys life and that's the great balance
you work hard you play hard and so for
Michael I think having have left the
game he has grown in his own way but
Michael still has the the personality
unlike any other
and so that personality would never have
go away and I appreciate his personality
Michael will give me a call and said man
if you haven't done this you need to go
do that and so he he is a caring person
I understand that most people only get a
chance to see her being on the back of
the name on the back of that Jersey but
I got a chance to know Irving the guy
well I mean when you talk about it Emma
- I'm with Emmitt Smith here in the Rich
Eisen show I I just told you off-camera
about my four years about to turn 40 so
it's coming up on the four year
anniversary of we had in my house a
baby-naming ceremony okay we couldn't
get the rabbi to the house on a Saturday
very well it was not easy because we
couldn't hold it on a Sunday because it
was football Sunday right so we went
through the whole you know concept of
what the ceremony was going to be in the
rabbi that we found said I have in my
ceremony I usually do this there's a
member of the family or whoever that
gets to speak at the end now my wife
knew Michael before I met Michael
because she worked with him at Fox
Sports and I come home one day and I'm
like there's a speaker's element to this
ceremony and I know one person to speak
it was Michael Irvin right and he gave
an incredible speech about family and
fatherhood and how certain aspects of
that are missing in today's society
right off the top of his head right he
is not off the top of his head is out of
his heart because you don't speak like
that if you don't really believe which
is what you're saying and so for Michael
to speak as you would say off the top of
head I say it can it came out of his
heart that's how you truly feel about
family and now your speech at the Hall
of Fame that was you memorized that to
write my own I worked doing it for six
months and so I wanted my speech to
become part of who I am I mean it is it
is my story and so I don't think I
needed notes to convey my story well I
want to take a 60-second break we'll
come back and we'll talk about the big
news of the day
Ezekiel Elliott I got twenty two in here
we'll talk about 21 when we come back
Pro Football Hall of Famers no other
human being on planet Earth has run for
more yards and experience more that then
Emmitt Smith back in one
here on the rich Ivan show
all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show he is Emmitt Smith Pro Football
Hall of Famer hanging out here in the
Rich Eisen show studio in person okay
what do you think of the news of the day
Emmitt that Ezekiel Elliott is missing
the first six games barring anything on
appeal Wow hey all I could say is wow
it's been so much news before twelve
o'clock it's crazy I know it's crazy um
unfortunately for the Cowboys we will be
losing a great football player and
unfortunately for Zeke
this is going to be the topic for the
next six to eight maybe two months in
terms of not being able to be on the
football field I helped his team and
hopefully this is a learning experience
for him because you have to look at it
from the standpoint of I am an impactful
player and now I cannot have an impact
because I am on a Cylon and being on the
sidelines is tough you're not injured
you physically can go out there and help
there's nothing you can do I equated to
missing the first two games of the year
back in 1992-93 you do know that you are
the last person to lead the league in
rushing and miss the first two games of
the following year because of your
holdout and Zeke is now the next one to
do that yeah so but it's six games I had
- that's right so I still had a chance
to fight to come back six games is
almost a half a season and so it's tough
I think there's a number of ways he can
look at this he can look at this as
punishment or you can look at this as an
opportunity opportunity for him to
understand - who much is given much is
required and and the impact that he's
had on his team and his organization has
been tremendous and he can still have
the same impact but he has to learn that
there are rules within only the game but
also society and and and I think he this
is the time to reflect and ask
fundamental questions of oneself do I
want a real long career in his national
football league which I can have
or do I just want to play a year-by-year
and have and just live for the now but
this is about its future and that's what
I'm really concerned about is his
feature because this is a tremendous
opportunity for a lot of athletes to be
able to do something that you absolutely
love and get compensated for it and be
able to have an impact in another
person's life that's what this NFL is
all about is this is this is temporary
we have a shelf life in this sport and I
like you have a career this is a chef's
life and so this doesn't last long and
so we have to take advantage of every
moment and mrs.six games right now is
not affording you the opportunity to
take advantage of every moment well in
terms of the six weeks he's not allowed
to be around the team at all I
understand and he's going to have to be
he's going to be at the crib if you will
and idle time for him so far has not
been productive is one very light way to
put it that's why that's why I say it's
a time of reflection so time to
self-analyze and and and I'm talking
because of wisdom I'm talking because
even when I missed those first two games
I had to do self analyzation in terms of
am I'm doing the right thing i'm i'm
missing my teammates they need me on
that fear when they wouldn't get beat by
the watch the redskins i didn't get beat
by i want to be on that football field
i can't stand watching them go into
battle without all of the tools that
they absolutely need i couldn't stand it
and so for z it's going to be tormenting
to watch someone else taking the reps
that he should be getting it's gonna be
tormenting and so i want to be a
sounding board for him just like many
other folks probably want to be a
sounding board for him want to help
because i want to see him become very
very successful but let me cut straight
to the heart of the matter as well
because there's been a lot written about
and discussed it has he ever sought you
out in that regard not necessarily
sought me out but i tell you what i
think we have we're getting closer i
think we are
getting closer I think you have to
develop a trust with a person and and he
has to develop a trust with me and and
he has to feel like he's had he has a
safe place well why wouldn't he trust
you I mean dad doesn't really he doesn't
really know me
but I mean des didn't really know
Michael earth very much and the two of
them bonded right off the bat he let he
let DES take the 88 right but I mean
people have to get to that place on
their own
I can't force him to a place he has to
get to that place on his own and and and
he's young and he's growing he's he has
has to grow into that role but I think
at some point he would get there and and
and I think steps have been taken and I
appreciate the the steps that have been
taking I cannot force something you got
to allow it to actually develop on its
own and as it develops naturally and
that trust is built then I think things
would go from there
Emmett Smith sooner than later well I
mean yeah and and just I guess to put a
button on it Emmett
so I mean we've we've heard what you
think he should do let's say you're
walking off the set here and your phone
rings and it is Ezekiel Elliott what
would you Emmitt Smith say to him the
first thing I want to know is how are
you feeling what's going in your head
right now what do you think I want to
understand where he's at and then then I
would probably want to have a
conversation in terms okay once we get
past certain levels what do we do from
here this devised a game plan for the
next six to seven maybe eight weeks to
develop a a a peer a veteran to peer
relationship how do we develop these
counter accountabilities how can we
become a kind of accountability partners
and not only that but let's get you in
the room with some other athletes that
been down this path and had to deal with
certain things so you can understand
where they all are coming from so it's
not just me because there are plenty
examples I mean you got herb you got
myself you got guys that would be
willing to reach out to help and support
him in any which way we can because we
want to see people become very
successful beyond the gate and teaching
the respect woman yeah mostly deaf is I
mean there's all these kind of
conversation but these a conversation
that you would have behind closed doors
if he needs that sort of it does and
just based on this letter it seems that
you know all of that that's a
conversation less than we have in my
opinion nothing is off the table
okay nothing is off today's how do you
think this affects the team this year
2017 tremendously chemistry is built
during these times
that's what training camps are really
there to force that the right chemistry
to go into the season which is
absolutely critical truss it's all built
right now and so understanding that is
happening now the team can shift its
focus to like Tony Romo got her last
year in the preseason the team was able
to shift his focus to debt Prescott no
doubt and the same thing happens now
it's shifting this focus knowing that
Zeke is not gonna be available for six
games and the rest of preseason and so
you shift your focus over 2 alpha Mars
and and and McFadden and Hillman and and
you start to develop your game plan
around what you currently have our poll
question Brockman read it out to a Matt
Smith here on the Richards children
where we get to ATT experience more go
for it Chris alright Emmett how many
wins do the Cowboys have after six games
so we have four options zero to two
option one three four or five or six so
their home for the Giants what do you
think I could take it one by one
yeah I would be having with would have
it it's 500 yeah 500 home for the Giants
there at the Broncos at the Cardinals
home for the Rams who now have Sammy
Watkins want a trade home for the
Packers by week at the 49ers I say I
said three and three maybe even four and
two and they've got a runt Emmitt
they've got to run it can't they can't
say okay our guys out let's lean on dak
and wing it around the laundry with the
algorithm 100% you stay true to who you
are right and you are a well balanced
offensive unit you can run the right
with these three guys that I just
mentioned you can still throw to rot
with which you have out there why would
Terrence and and des and and and Beasley
and Beasley along with Jason win you
still you got enough weapons offensively
so stay true to form do not try to get
outside of out of your comfort zone they
did do not put more pressure on Dagda
needs to be there so three and three is
something I think the way three as
possible so let's talk about the eyewear
that you're wearing and have been
wearing this entire conversation and the
technology is called IRA and you're
going to help one lucky AT&T consumer is
blind or has low vision visualize an
actual Dallas Cowboys game yeah yeah
they're gonna do glasses they're gonna
join me at a cowboy game on October the
first I believe and I'm go against the
Rams yes gets around Rams and I'm gonna
sit up in this in the box and we're
going to talk about what I'm seeing and
I'm a relay the game to them so they can
get this visual effect of what's
actually transpiring on the football
field these glasses are pretty awesome
I'm enjoying the technology this is a
way to communicate to the to the
visually impaired and help them
understand what's going on around them I
can describe what's in the room and they
get this visual context of what's
happened that's incredible
technology is amazing how is bridging so
many gaps between what you once could do
versus what you can absolutely do now is
bringing all kinds of things back to
back to focus so if you or a friend or
family member has low vision or blind
and want to be able to experience more
and share this whole experience with
Emmitt Smith certainly go to experience
more dot a att.com
or use the hash tag experience more
exactly fantastic spirits more I love it
and good for you gonna do the stairs has
it really been my time with you what do
you think of the studio here I love it
this is a studio built for King in urk
I'll take that before before I let you
go Leonard fournette says that the game
slower than he thought it would be maybe
he's just fast well he was he said it
was playing in the SEC that led that's
aiding him in getting more equipped to
the speed of the game well what do you
think of that I think Leonard fournette
knows his offense a lot quicker than
most people give him credit for because
that's the only way the game slows down
how do you think he's going to do this
year we'll see I think he has a
tremendous opportunity he's a big guy
they need a little bit more space than
Kristin McAfee but they like girly hit
the scenes and hit the scenes running
from the SEC if some is so how was your
transition from the SEC to the NFL but
you sell more Ricky you do know are in
the Jerry Dome my alma mater takes on
yours to start the college football
season yeah yeah I will be there you
will be there I will Jerry don't I will
not I would be there slipping a cold
it's my daughter's first birthday party
she has no idea that she'll be spending
it somewhat with Jim Harbaugh on
television always on it yes sir small
ways you wouldn't want to do that we
want just a small weight well normally
what we do is uh one of us the loser has
to wear no no I'm not wearing nothing
avatar I'm not wearing it Twitter avatar
Avatar Twitter avatar you change your
Twitter avatar to to a blocking log on
another is too much too much visibility
that one's name that's the point of it
we're talking about vision here you're
talking about we are to my vision but
I'm going to put of damn yours down a
little bit I'm working summer I said
friendly front pisser back right you got
to be all in everybody's face mmm that's
free well sounds I'm like scared I'm
like sending you come on like a like a
like a coupon to go to Houston's for
lunch or something like that I'm trying
to be sort of describe what you and TD
with you
now I'm giving you a piece of me in a
nice little a and vice-versa
so what what piece of me would you want
no pieces that's not apples to apples
here that's true that's true you are
sour agree mmm
we'll have to figure something out
that's why I'm singing a Twitter avatar
for one day one day I've got to put a
hater note no offense I've got one I've
got I've got a following I've got to put
a gator on mine you have a following
okay I've got him I've got to put a
gator at Rich Eisen for a full day and I
got to put it in lock him mmm
for one full day I don't know come on oh
no my spirit can take that let's do it
that would hurt Oh or this Michigan
helmet on my desk you've got to hold it
or something take a picture of it with
it I think it's just tell you what yes I
take a picture with it right now
yes oh I get to use that you get to use
that on my Twitter on your toilet avatar
if so but what happens if mrs. Florida
wins you get to use my Gator we have a
deal
and that you put I've got to put a
Florida helmet on this desk for a day
that's why win see that's how you
negotiate I got two things deal
I've got Gator on the death and I got an
avatar oh well could you they only got
war okay did I just get hosed
no it'll be good good it'll be great
Emmitt Smith we're going to take a break
when we come back and it's going to say
cheese because that's what I'm gonna use
on September the 3rd Labor Day Sunday at
how a big ok ok
even if I have to dress Emmett a frill
that you were here thrilled that you
were here thank you mother
please come back anytime you are in Los
Angeles and again experience more dot
att.com or use the hashtag experience
more to learn more enter right now for a
chance to go to the Rams Cowboys game
with Emmitt Smith and through the IRA
technology if you are of low vision or
blind he will help you visualize the
game thanks to the folks at AT&T you're
the man thank you bro Emmitt Smith here
on the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stay
since across the country and audience if
you liked that video be sure to download
it on and I'll be sure to move week six
games to Saturday for that wedding you
have to go to